chris has just said may need to give it
a minute so it might be
it does take a while to set the
streaming back up
it does yes i think everyone's there by
the looks of it
i think chair if we just tell them we're
just waiting for the live streaming to
be confirmed again
as far as the applicant objects
it looks like you're ready now chair if
you want to
restart many thanks thanks um
by unanimous sorry yes by unanimous
decision
we have decided to reject this
application we did not feel the
application
um was uh sufficiently uh
of sufficiently clear to us and we are
concerned that the applicant wouldn't be
able to meet the licensing objectives
we granted the license so for that
reason we have decided
not to grant any of the licenses
there is a right of appeal within 21
days the local magistrates
within five days we will give detailed
written explanations to all interested
parties of
why we made these decisions i would
thank the applicant and i would thank
the objective for giving up their time
today to come
and it was helpful uh information and it
helped us to make our decisions
thank you very much indeed and i think
with that i'm
going to close the meeting thank you
thank you jeff